[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADAM MICHELSON: Thanks
for joining our session.
I'm Adam Michelson.
I am a product manager here
at Google on the IoT team.
Joining me shortly
will be a couple
of folks from our partner,
Cognite, Geir Engdahl
and Sindre Hammerlund.
So they'll be coming
up in a minute
and describing, in
detail, their expertise
around IoT and industrial.
But before we dive in on
that, I wanted to just do
a quick informal survey.
So for the folks in the room,
around IoT, Internet of Things,
how many folks in the room have
deployed an IoT implementation,
just by show of hands, or
are planning to do so say,
in the next 12 months?
Wow, that's a lot of people.
So that's exciting to hear.
What we've seen
from analysts is,
there's basically a claim that
somewhere between 8 billion
and 14 billion IoT devices
exist out there today.
And that's a lot of devices.
It's also a big range,
8 to 14 billion.
I think one of the reasons might
be, when you think about IoT,
a lot of the implementations
we see use a gateway, right?
Like, If you think of
this room, and if you
want to control all
the lights via IoT,
then a lot of the
implementations we see is,
there'll be a central box
somewhere, some Linux machine,
that all these lights are
talking to on-premises,
and then that gateway
will connect to a cloud.
So what is it that is the
counting as the 8 billion?
Is it the one gateway or is
it each individual light?
I don't know.
I feel sorry for
the poor analyst
who's going around counting
those 8 billion devices.
But it's a lot of devices,
more and more all the time.
And all of those devices are
generating incredible amounts
of data.
And dealing with the
intake of all that data
is one of the challenges
when it comes to IoT.
Even though there are so
many devices that are online,
there's another statistic
which isn't so great,
and I don't know what the
experience of the audience
is, that we've seen that
people claim that around 1%
of the data that's
actually collected for IoT
is actually used to
generate some sort
of a positive outcome,
business outcome.
And so what's happening to
that other 99% of the data that
is not generating that outcome?
There is an opportunity
there for everyone
to say, how are we going
to collect this data
and make sure that the
data we're collecting
has a maximal value.
So that's one of the
purposes, where we can
see Google's mission come in.
So Google's mission
is to organize
the world's information and
make it universally useful.
So when it comes to,
say, Google search,
that's easy to think about.
Pulling up information
from lots of websites,
organizing it so
that it makes sense,
providing a nice,
handy search bar
that you can type into,
and then at the end,
giving you useful results.
So you tie that chain together.
IoT has the same
opportunity, where
we're collecting all this data.
It needs to be organized
in a uniform way,
and then made useful.
So we think about the
lights in the room
are collecting one type of
IoT data, or telemetric data.
The HVAC system
might be another one.
The alarm systems, another one.
How is all this data
being collected,
organized to make
sense, and then
produce a useful outcome
that has business value.
So some of that is
some of the topics
we want to talk about today.
But before diving right into
the industrial use cases,
I just want to spend a couple of
minutes and baseline us on what
are Google's IoT
offerings, so we
know what the terms are and
all have a common understanding
before we dive deep into
the industrial use cases.
So this is an image of
Google's IoT platform.
For those who haven't seen
it, it's called IoT Core.
IoT Core is a component
that exists within Google
Cloud, Google Cloud Services.
IoT Core has a few major
components built into it.
One component is
this protocol bridge.
That is what will enable us
to take these edge devices
and safely and securely send
that data into the cloud.
We often will talk HTTP, or a
more popular protocol for IoT
is MQTT, which is very
efficient for IoT use cases.
The other component of IoT
Core is this Device Manager,
which allows us to understand
each and every device.
Both, like the example
we were talking
about before, the gateway.
Like, in this room, if we
had a gateway of lights,
we would want to understand the
gateway that's talking to us,
but also each device
that's connected
to that gateway would want to
be known to the Device Manager.
So as data is being sent from
these devices into the cloud,
we can say, oh, that's a.
Light and that's an HVAC.
And that's an alarm.
Or whatever it may be.
Another component of IoT
Core are some edge modules,
where we have libraries
that you can take,
embed into your edge devices,
that have pre-built connections
to IoT Core.
You don't have to use
those edge components.
You can use the raw APIs of
the IoT Core cloud modules.
But those components are there
and extensible for you just
for a quick start so
you can get your IoT
journey going a little faster.
Now, behind IoT Core is
the rest of Google Cloud.
The first module we
connect to is Pub/Sub.
It's a large message bus
that's used across many Google
components to allow
services to interoperate.
Once the data gets
to Pub/Sub, then it
can be sent to other
Google services.
Commonly, we see services
such as data flow,
that can transform data.
So for example, if have a data
coming in from a light and data
coming in from an HVAC, and
they're in different formats,
we have to make
them look common.
Dataflow will help us do that.
We can also call
cloud functions if we
want to run business logic
on real time data that's
coming in in a streaming way.
And then many
services behind that
to store the data, we
have multiple storage
options that you can choose
based on what type of data
it is, how frequently
it's coming in,
how frequently you want to
do analytics on that data.
And then there
are analysis tools
that we have, such as Data
Studio, as well as a suite
of machine learning tools.
So this is not all the
Google components, clearly,
but it's ones that we typically
see on an IoT implementation.
You heard,
potentially, yesterday
in the keynote about multi
cloud and hybrid cloud.
And a lot of the
implementations we see
aren't quite as clean as every
single component up here is
one of these Google components.
Which we'd love to see,
but we have many partners
and there are many
players in IoT.
So oftentimes, this
architecture is a suite of tools
that we see between Google
components, partner components,
to come together
for an architecture.
So one way to sort of think
about the various components
that are involved in
an IoT architecture
is this simple three buckets.
On the left, we see
ingestion to gather the data.
So IoT Core is there
to get the data.
Sometimes you have data that
doesn't need an IoT broker.
It's already ready
to be ingested.
So for that, you can use
something like Pub/Sub
just to take the data ingested.
In the middle, we need to
clean up that data, process it.
And it's the organized
step in the Google mission.
Here we see Dataflow
functions, data storage,
various components.
On the far right
is where we have
to do analysis and
understand this data.
And if we don't see Google
components in all of these,
that's fine.
What's more important is,
for the folks in the room
implementing this,
that they have
a way of laying out
the components you're
going to have in your IoT
and know what functions
they're going to operate on.
So before, when we were
seeing 99% of the data in IoT
is not reaching
its full potential.
A lot of the reason why
is because the process
and clean step isn't cleaning
up the data as much as we need,
so the data is looking
like it's in data silo
from the lights in the
HVAC and et cetera.
And the other reason is because
there's so much of this data.
It's not hard for
a single device
to generate gigabytes
of data in a single year
if that device is talking
multiple times per minute
or multiple times per second.
And then multiply that
times all the devices,
and we're talking about
it enormous data load
to be able to
understand that data.
So we just don't have
the human capital
to go through all that data.
And that's where tools like--
let me go back one--
the machine learning
tools come in that
will help us understand,
over here on the right,
to review all that data so
that-- let the machine look
at the data and figure out how
to find the insights rather
than the people.
And that's why ML and
IoT go together so well.
So on the next slide, I wanted
to talk about machine learning,
where machine learning also has
lots of tools you could use.
So what's a
framework that we can
think about in terms of which
mL components we want to use?
And this is another
block of three.
So here on the left, we
have Google components that
are pre-built, ready to use.
Our data, our model.
Meaning, for example, vision.
We have a Google vision
machine learning component
that you can upload an image.
A pizza, here's a pizza.
And Google will say,
I think that's pizza.
And then you can go
ahead and use that data.
Or it's a building,
or it's a dog.
That sort of thing.
And these components
on the left,
there are more and more
of them all the time.
Very simple to
use, a great place
to start your ML journey
with all this data.
But oftentimes you'll say,
OK, I know that's a pizza,
but I run a pizza
company and I wanted
to know that it's
one of my pizzas,
because I have all these
different pizzas that I make.
So how can I train that model?
And that's where the
middle components,
the retrained models,
AutoML will come in.
So like, AutomL Vision
is a tool you can use.
And the models are pre-built,
but the training is not.
And here, you'll upload an
image and say, here's pizza,
and it's my supreme pizza.
And here's another one, and
it's my, whatever, deep dish.
And these are the others.
So that Google will
learn those images,
so when it sees images
of those in the future,
maybe as the pizzas are
coming out of the oven
and you want to make
sure it's matching what
the customer ordered, somebody
could take a picture of it,
match the point of
sale, and say, yep,
that's the supreme pizza,
just like the customer
ordered with extra mushrooms.
And that's where tools
like AutoML can come in.
Any of that training
you do is your data.
None of it would
filter into the left.
None of it filters into Google.
It's all your data.
And then sometimes,
customers need even more.
They need not only
custom trained models,
but they need to build
their own models.
And that's where the
data scientists defined
the rules you need,
defined the data sets.
You can create great
tools like TensorFlow,
either the open source or
the hosted version on Google,
and have models that are
custom to your business.
And customers will
often start on the left,
use the out of the box ones,
and work their way to the right
as they need to.
Because the more you go to
the right, the more coding
you have to do.
And the more coding
you have to do,
the less you're worrying
about your core business.
And so that's why we
offer this suite of tools.
So with that, we have a baseline
of IoT core and the components.
So now what I want to
do is invite Geir up,
and he's going to
describe to how Cognite
has taken these tools, assembled
them in an industrial IoT use
case, and brought them
into the real world.
And he'll share with us some
of the lessons they've learned
and some of the tips for all
of us to take advantage of.
Geir?
Thank you.
GEIR ENGDAHL: Thank you, Adam.
[APPLAUSE]
Hello, everyone.
My name is Geir.
I'm CTO and
co-founder of Cognite,
which is a software
company that works
with asset heavy industries.
What that means is,
basically, industry
that has big machines
that cost lots of money.
So we've worked mainly
with oil and gas,
also in power and
utilities, and shipping.
Now, this talk will
focus on shipping
because it is the most
challenging edge environment
that we've encountered.
But before we dive into
that, I want to make sure
that you're all awake.
So, quick show of hands,
how many of you have
had a cup of coffee
this morning?
Yes, that's what I thought.
As we all know, coffee
is one of the primary
or most important inputs to
writing a good software code.
But what are the
inputs to coffee?
It turns out that coffee sits
at the top of a very long,
complex industrial value chain.
And you don't have to backtrack
very far to understand this,
because the beans, before
they came to Moscone,
they were on a truck.
And that truck needed fuel,
hence the oil and gas industry.
Or, where I'm from,
in Norway, I believe
60% of new vehicles sold
last month were electric.
So maybe you have power
and utilities too.
And the truck needed to be
manufactured from steel,
so you have mining, steel mills.
And before the beans
got onto the truck,
they were probably on a ship.
So there's this
huge value chain,
which touches all the
industries that we are in.
And it's not just coffee.
It's everything that
we surround ourselves
with that kind of make our lives
comfortable and convenient.
And that's why I think
it's such a privilege
to use data and algorithms
to drive industry
to be more efficient, produce
more for less energy input,
make it safer.
It's really quite
the potential there.
So when we started
Cognite, we set out,
and we had this
kind of naive belief
that we would use sensor
data and would do ML on that,
and things would be great.
Now, it turns out, industry
is a little bit different
from consumer in that there
are so many different data
silos, different protocols,
different systems that you
have to integrate with.
And in order to understand
the sensor data,
you need a lot of
context around it.
So maybe you need
the engineering data.
Maybe you need the CAD
model to figure out
where the sensor
actually is located,
or need the topology
of how stuff
flows through a power plant.
And so we were very
lucky to start out
with a large industrial
customer very
early to be exposed to
this reality of industry.
And I think the core problem
is that the lifecycle
of industrial equipment
is so much longer
than the lifecycle of software.
A plant that's five
years old is new.
Software that's five
years old is old.
So then, with this data
complexity that we witness,
our mission quickly became
to liberate all this data
from the industrial silos
and move it to somewhere
where it's always available.
And clean it so that it becomes
understandable, so that it's
easy to build value from it.
As you can see, it's quite
a complex reality out there.
As Adam was saying, the
scale of data is enormous.
A single sensor sending
one value per second
will produce one gigabyte
of data every two years.
And that doesn't
sound like a lot,
but the typical ship
has 5,000 of these.
An oil platform
can have 100,000.
So it becomes a lot of
data, and that actually
informed our choice of
Google Cloud as the vendor,
because we believe in
the ability of Google
to run distributed systems at
a scale that's one step ahead
of everyone else.
So we want to reuse the
same infrastructure that's
powering YouTube, Google
search, and Gmail to store
all this data.
For instance, we're storing all
the IoT data, all the sensor
data time series,
in a system called
Bigtable, which is a
ridiculously distributed
key value store.
And how we structure
data into Bigtable
to be able to query
it efficiently
and store data efficiently,
could fill an entire talk.
And in fact, it does.
I did a talk on that
last year at Next.
So if you're interested
in the details of that,
you can Google
Cognite Next Bigtable
and you'll find that talk.
As someone who loves
technology, it's really easy
to get kind of sidetracked
into building technology
for technology's sake.
And that usually doesn't lead
to great outcomes in the end.
And I've been guilty
of that in my past.
So it makes sense to sit down
with the people in industry,
figure out what the real
valuable use cases are.
And some of these
use cases will span--
we see in every vertical,
every industry that we are in,
such a fuel efficiency, or
energy efficiency in general.
Nobody wants to waste energy.
Energy is a cost.
In fact, in shipping, it
is the number one cost.
A single percent
reduction in fuel costs
for an average freight ship is
a $50k per ship annual savings.
And for a fleet of 100
ships, that's $5 million.
And by the way, we're
not targeting 1%.
So our customers
estimate anywhere
from 5% to 15% savings,
depending on the type of ship
and the age of the ship.
And then there are
other use cases,
which are specific
to each industry,
such as weather impact on cargo.
You want to be able to
tell your customer that you
didn't damage the goods.
And you can measure the motion
of the ship at any time.
So you can kind
of say, hey, look.
I didn't go through
too rough seas.
This is what a data
silo looks like.
We had this great piece
of equipment, a sensor,
that is using lasers to measure
the torque on the propeller
axle on the ship.
So it's like the
laser underwater
sending a beam along the axle.
It's reflected.
It's detected.
It measures the
microscopic deformation
of the axle due to the
force enacted on it.
Now, contrast that with
the way that this data
is sent to the cloud.
Because what happens
is, every day, this guy
walks down to the
engine control room
and writes down the value
on a piece of paper,
and it goes into a report.
But that's not-- the reason
this particular measure is
important is, if you want to
solve the energy efficiency use
case for a ship, you need
to be able to break down
the fuel used to ship motion
into its two main parts.
That's the engine efficiency.
So how much force do
you get onto the water
via the propeller
for each unit of fuel
used, and the hull performance.
So for the force that the
propeller acts on the water,
how far do you go?
And a once per day resolution
is nowhere near what
you need to solve the use case.
Because the engine
settings change too often.
Weather changes all the time.
So here, to get the data out,
we had to install an adapter.
And this is a pretty
common pattern.
So the data set's in
a separate network.
You can't talk to it on
the ship's network, which
converts the data and sends it
onto the ship ethernet, where
it can be picked
up by an edge box.
And you have many
of these systems
that you need to
liberate data from.
Here's another issue.
Connectivity.
The good news is that you can
be connected virtually anywhere
on the planet.
The bad news, it's kind of
expensive and the bandwidth
is not great.
One of the things that
surprised me about this
is that you actually get
quite decent latency.
Your data can go from
the laser to the cloud
in 200 milliseconds.
I find that pretty awesome.
But we have too much data to
send over this connection.
And most of the data is not
that useful for this use case
anyway.
So given those
constraints, here's
how we approached
solving the situation.
First, given the
bandwidth constraints,
there is a need for
an edge component.
It needs to manage
the bandwidth.
So some of the data
is high priority
and should be sent
directly to the cloud.
Some of the data
needs to be buffered
on the edge, stored there
until connectivity is better.
When the ship is
close to shore, it
will get cellular
coverage, which
is much cheaper
and much wider when
you can bulk upload that data.
You also may want to do
some processing on the data.
Down sampling or compressing
the data in other ways.
For instance, vibration
sensors on rotating equipment
will often send you
data at 50 kilohertz.
So that's 50,000 data
points per second.
That's like, 10 times
more than the rest
of the sensors on the ship.
You can't send all of that data.
And you don't need to.
Because if you do a Fourier
transform, convert the signal
into the frequency
space, and send
the coefficients of each
frequency that constitutes
the signal, then you get
almost exactly the same curve
with 1/1000 of the
data transmitted,
which is also a very cool stat.
And you may also want
to use it as a cache.
If you have applications
on the ship,
if you have like, a digital
worker application running
on Android phones where
the workers on the ship
can get all the sensor data
from the ship at any time,
they may not want to go
via the cloud for that.
So you can ask the
edge box directly.
And there are also more
interesting use cases
which we will get into, which
does more interesting computes
and predictions on the edge.
Also, this is not your
typical IoT consumer scenario
where you have to have
very, very light hardware.
It actually makes sense to
invest in rugged hardware that
won't break, in this case.
And it also needs
a bit of storage
because it needs to
buffer all this data.
An average ship will
produce something
like 500 megabytes
per day of data.
And it can be at sea for
up to two months at a time.
So you need some
storage there and.
You also don't want to lose
that data if one disk dies.
So it's a RAID configuration.
It has a rugged PC
with no moving parts.
So here's what the
architecture looks like.
You have all these silos at
the bottom, the green boxes.
They're typically on
their own networks.
You can't access them
via the ship network.
So you need a physical adapter.
And in our case,
those are always
set up to be read only, which
makes the whole situation less
scary from a security
point of view.
Then it's picked
up by the edge box.
And what it needs
to do is translate
from all of these different
industrial protocols.
Here we have the modbus,
the OPC, OPC-UA, MQTT,
and a wide variety of other
dialects that you need to talk.
Once you've translated the
data into a sane format,
put it on another queue,
and then it's processed.
It's matched against the list
of high priority [? tax. ?]
And some is sent directly
over the satellite link, which
is managed by Cloud IoT Core.
And the other data
is stored and sent
over a cell phone connection.
One of the things
that we didn't do,
which we are considering
doing, is to move to EdgeX.
EdgeX is a framework
for edge solutions,
which will do some of
the translation for you.
And it has a lot of components
that you can put together
to solve for many
of these scenarios.
One of the things--
so Cognite is almost
200 people, and it's
just over two years old.
One of the things that we
value very highly is speed.
And one of the things
that we do to get speed
is to always try to use
managed solutions where we can.
You don't want to
reinvent the wheel.
And when you're looking
at this next slide,
you might wonder if
we do anything at all.
Because it looks like Google
is doing all the work.
But there is some stuff there.
Like, Cloud
Functions, we actually
write the stuff that's
in the Cloud Function,
and the Kubernetes engine, where
we have our business logic.
So on the cloud side,
basically, what IoT Core
gives us is a
managed connection.
We don't need to
scale that thing.
And it has encryption.
Authentication is taken care of.
And it conveniently
puts the data
on the Pub/Sub queue, which we
use for the rest of our system.
So it's, to us, it's--
we just interact with
the Pub/Sub queue.
Which triggers Cloud
Function, which
translates the data on the
queue into API culls to our API
gateway.
So our solution is
used by many customers
in many verticals,
many industries,
which have slightly different
ways of sending data.
So not all of it is
going through IoT Core.
And that's why the
API kind of accessed
the one gate, which is the
common denominator there.
That's why you need
that translation.
Same thing with the daily
logs, the backfilled data.
It's uploaded to GCP--
Google Cloud Storage, I mean.
And that triggers a
Cloud Function whenever
a new file is uploaded.
Which does the same translation.
So it's the same protocol
buffer-based format.
Now when we get
to the yellow box,
we have a pipeline for
processing the data,
structuring it so that it
doesn't use a lot of space,
and computing roll ups so that
you can do advanced queries
with millisecond latency.
And this pipeline, we've
run at 10 million data
points per second.
So every component there, like
Kubernetes engine, AutoScaler,
Pub/Sub, scales incredibly
well, and Bigtable.
So it all scales horizontally.
And it's very fast.
And then when we do run
predictions on this data,
we use ML Engine to
host those models.
And we use Cloud Scheduler
to do periodic predictions.
So we don't write back
to the control systems.
So the use cases that we
have are about advising,
say, the captain.
You know, you need
to slow down a bit
because you're
using too much fuel.
Or you need to clean the hull,
because there's marine growth,
which is slowing you down.
It's something that you
can do periodically.
Maybe you do a
prediction every minute.
But we do-- you
can think of cases
where you'd want to do
streaming, analytics,
when it comes in.
But right now,
it's not necessary.
Security.
So the edge environment
is kind of scary.
The control systems
that you deal with there
are set up that they
usually don't have
the concept of authentication.
So if you can talk
to them, you can
do whatever you want with them.
A couple of principles
that we imply,
we don't want to invent
their own encryption scheme.
We let Google IoT
Core handle that.
We have no inbound
routes to the edge.
And there's a physically
separated network.
So we only read
to these sensors.
So that makes it a lot less
scary to be on the edge.
But security is definitely
a big concern here.
So bringing that together.
Here we have one
of the dashboards,
which will show you and verify
that the cargo was not damaged.
This is the ship's motion in
all the different directions,
axles, at 10 Hertz with
200 milliseconds latency.
So if you're shipping
cars, for instance, you
could share this with
the car manufacturer
and really assert that you
didn't damage any of the goods.
It's also very important input
to the energy efficiency use
case.
Because if you have
rough seas, your engine
will have to work more.
In fact, very rough seas can
make the engines shut down
entirely, which is what
happened with the cruise ship,
Viking Sky, a
couple of weeks ago
outside the coast of Norway.
We had rough seas
and the engines
tripped as a result of
that, leaving the ship
in a very precarious situation.
And then when we move on to the
more advanced use cases that
involve machine learning,
you have an, of course,
anomaly detection,
which is very much
used in predictive analytics.
The models there
are usually based
on clustering or forecasting.
So you're looking for data
that you haven't seen before,
basically.
And then you're
alerting someone.
Inspection.
We have a lot of sensors
that are not just
pressure, temperature, flow.
We have a sensor in our
pocket, which is a camera.
And you can use that
to extract loads
of interesting information
using image recognition.
So inspection, and
we've trained--
for instance, last year,
we trained an auto ML model
which detected damaged wires.
And you can imagine having
drones to fly around and detect
these faulty things, or
corrosion, which is already
being done by some companies.
And in those cases,
you definitely
do not want to send all
the footage to the cloud
if you were on a
satellite connection.
DANIELSON: [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
So, Geir, I heard some
rumors about your demo
last year, that you did some--
had the windmill
on stage and did
some machine learning as well?
That must have been
pretty terrifying.
GEIR ENGDAHL: Yes.
A good demo is exciting to
the audience, and very scary
to the presenter.
So I think, especially
when you have moving parts
and you're doing
machine learning--
which is never really 100%--
that's always scary.
But you know, the one trick is,
you can always blame the Wi-Fi.
[LAUGHTER]
But yeah, so I
think we should we
should try to top
that and do something
even scarier this year.
STEIN H. DANIELSON:
Yeah, definitely.
And that's why we brought this
tiny model of a chemical plant.
It continuously streams
live sensor data
to Cognite Data Fusion
via Google IoT Core.
So typically, you
use this sensor data
to visualize it
in charts like you
can see soon on this screen.
So here you can see
the temperature,
it's about 27 degrees.
That's pretty hot.
But there are other ways to
visualize your data, as well.
In Cognite, we see the power
of using 3D models as a tool
to visualize your data.
And that is definitely, I
use a tool for the future.
GEIR ENGDAHL: I see that.
But what if you don't
have a 3D model?
STEIN H. DANIELSON:
That's definitely
a big issue and a
challenge for the industry.
Because either you
don't have a 3D model,
or perhaps the 3D
model already got
old from the day of assembly
and has become kind of useless.
So that's why we have
developed an application that
helps you generate these
up-to-date 3D models in order
to visualize your
data in a better way.
GEIR ENGDAHL: You're
not connected, I think.
STEIN H. DANIELSON: OK.
GEIR ENGDAHL: It's the Wi-Fi.
STEIN H. DANIELSON: Yeah,
definitely the Wi-Fi.
So what we can see here
is the model on screen.
I take a single picture and
I detect features on it.
I could take one more,
and then it guides me
through the entire process.
So this is something that
I do now on my phone,
but this is something that you
can do with any kind of camera.
And it's not something that you
have to do yourself, either.
GEIR ENGDAHL: Yeah.
So you just need the
photos for this to work,
you don't need a special camera.
You might wonder why
there's a helipad here.
That's because, sometimes when
we run this, we use a drone.
Unfortunately, if
you look closely
on the sign outside
the door here,
it says no drones are allowed.
And the complexity of getting
that permission in time
was unfortunately
too high for us.
But it doesn't matter,
you can use anything--
like a mobile phone, or a drone,
or a GoPro on someone's helmet.
It doesn't really matter.
STEIN H. DANIELSON: Yeah.
GEIR ENGDAHL: So what's
happening to those pictures
right now?
STEIN H. DANIELSON: Yeah.
Now that I'm finished
taking the pictures,
I just upload them to
Cognite Data Fusion,
where the magic happens.
And right now, it's
processing all the pictures.
And should we take a look
at the final results?
GEIR ENGDAHL: All right.
Let's try that.
Now I'm scared.
STEIN H. DANIELSON: If
not, the Wi-Fi has failed.
GEIR ENGDAHL: Ooh, ooh!
Yes.
And here it looks like
we got a nice model.
STEIN H. DANIELSON:
So suddenly we
have a 3D model
that's up-to-date
with exact same dimension,
the exact same proportion.
And also, you get a good
overview of the texture
on the model, as well.
GEIR ENGDAHL: But if you
want to view the time
series in the right
context, here, I guess
you have to do some
kind of manual--
STEIN H. DANIELSON: Yeah.
Yeah.
So the thing is, that this is
definitely a really good tool
for the future of the industry.
But the thing is
that, wouldn't it
be cool if we could link
this model with the data
that we have inside the
Cognite Data Fusion platform?
And that's actually
something that we can do.
So if we take a close
look on the tags that
are located all around this
model, you can see T-02, T-01.
Those kinds of tags
is something that
is present on all platforms,
or in ships, as well,
and identify the
different assets.
That identifier is
something that we also
have in Cognite Data Fusion.
So what we can do, is to use the
same pictures that we took here
and try to detect all
the different tags using
Google Vision.
And when we have
detected them, we
store the location of
all the different assets,
and also which asset it is.
GEIR ENGDAHL: So we'll see
if it got them in the right--
STEIN H. DANIELSON: And
the end result is here.
[APPLAUSE]
GEIR ENGDAHL: So what was
happening behind the scene
there, is we used a model called
YOLO, You Only Look Once, which
is an object detection model.
And that thing is trained
to look for these--
STEIN H. DANIELSON: Tags there.
GEIR ENGDAHL: The tags.
But it can identify
other stuff too,
like rust, or faulty
wires, et cetera,
and place it right
there in the 3D model.
That's instant situational
awareness, there.
This room is too hot.
STEIN H. DANIELSON: So we
can demonstrate this for you.
Let's see if I'm hotter or
cooler than 28.2 degrees.
So I'm cooler.
GEIR ENGDAHL: Yeah.
STEIN H. DANIELSON:
I'm almost dead.
GEIR ENGDAHL: I guess maybe
you have some cold feet, too?
STEIN H. DANIELSON: Yeah.
But then we're inside the
operational limit again,
and that's good.
Because it turns red
but it's above 27.
GEIR ENGDAHL: Yeah.
You're actually
cooling the room down.
STEIN H. DANIELSON: Yeah.
So, yeah.
And this a model that
you can update 24/7,
at least when you have a robot
to take the pictures for you.
And that's really
convenient when
it comes to detect
when corrosion started.
You can actually
travel back in time,
you can check whether the
corrosion mark was there
only two weeks ago, or
perhaps two years ago.
So to conclude, five
minutes ago, we only
had a chemical plant that
streamed live sensor data.
But now, we also have
an up-to-date 3D model
that displays our sensor values
in a really intuitive way.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
GEIR ENGDAHL: And
you can do this
with real industrial
equipment, too.
This is data now streaming
in from the North Sea,
and it identified the plates
on that equipment, too.
And also, here, you
can find some things
that shouldn't be here.
For instance, these ladders.
They're not supposed
to be in this zone,
so it's a health safety
environment issue, right there.
Then let's wrap up.
Here's my checklist.
I wish this checklist was
shorter, but it's not.
This is the reality of why
it's hard to create value
in industry.
So you have to start with
the valuable use cases.
Start with that, and talk to
the people in the business
because you will depend on
them to implement it later.
So it better be something that
they think is valuable, too.
Then, you need to
figure out if you
have the data that's necessary
to solve those use cases.
Usually, you have
the sensors, but you
may have to do some work
to liberate the data.
And then you need
to clean the data,
make it so that you can
actually solve your use cases.
For instance, linking
it to a 3D model.
It may seem trivial
when you have, kind of,
a plant with four sensors.
But if you have 100,000 sensors,
and you send the data scientist
in to find the right sensors
to do predictive maintenance
on your one compressor
or whatever,
it's going to take months if you
don't have good tools to figure
out what sensor is
where, and which,
and relevant to the use case.
Then you need to do stuff with
the data, so that's algorithms.
Usually, you don't
build your own.
You merely apply
other people's work.
Most companies don't do
machine learning research,
they do application of known
research to new problems.
Now once you're satisfied
with those results,
you need to monitor the
quality of the data.
Because your mobile probably
won't handle garbage data
coming in.
And these systems,
these sensors,
will give you a lot of crap
data from time to time.
There will be
connectivity issues.
There will be flipping
bits here and there.
It's a quite challenging
thing to do, so
have to build that
trust in the data.
And then you have to
change the way that people
work in the company.
And there, it's very useful
if you've kind of introduced
your use case early on,
so they know this is not
something you made up.
Worst case, you've
done a lot of work,
and you get to this
stage, and it's
like, hey, this isn't useful.
That sucks.
And then last, that's when
you've done all those things.
You profit.
And that's what IoT
is really about,
otherwise it's not sustainable.
Here are some pointers
to get you started.
So for IoT Core, all the
AI solutions that Google
has to offer, we have a
booth down in the lower level
and there are
industry solutions.
So it's on the left after
taking the escalator down.
Come talk to us there
if you have questions.
Thank you.
And also, don't forget
to rate this talk.
We definitely appreciate your
feedback so that, you know,
next year we can have an
even better talk and even
scarier demo.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]